all right well thank you very much for
coming I'm Richard Crump
of ecology and evolutionary biology and
director of the Frankie program in
science and humanities welcome to
today's event as always I'm interested
in thanking the Frankie's for their
ongoing support and also to the Whitney
for making this possible today's speaker
is Carl Craver who is a distinguished
historian and philosopher of science
particularly of neuroscience he studied
history and philosophy of science at the
University of Pittsburgh and he teaches
at Washington University where he is a
full professor of in the Department of
Philosophy and in the program in
philosophy neuroscience and psychology
Craver is the author of dozens of
peer-reviewed articles and two books on
philosophy of neuroscience and his work
focuses particularly on clarifying the
nature of explanation in neuroscience
the critique of reductionist law like
accounts of causal explanation and the
support of alternative accounts of
explanation that focus on mechanistic or
mechanism at multiple levels his work is
notable for sophistication of engagement
both with philosophy and with ongoing
empirical programs in neuroscience so
today Carl will be talking to us about
new work on the phenomenon of episodic
amnesia what these maladies reveal about
the complexity of time perception and
how these complexities or what
implications these complexities may have
for uses of the concept of time
perception in in in neuroscience today
Carl will also be speaking tomorrow as
well at the unli on Centre at the
Medical School at 4:15 where he'll be
talking on graphing the brain's dark
energy Network models and neural
mechanism and please join me in
welcoming
thank you very much for coming out today
and it's cold out there and I appreciate
you being here the talk that I'm going
to give today is somewhat distant from
my traditional interests in the
philosophy of science normally I work on
the nature of scientific explanation but
for the past three or four years I've
found myself engaged in a research
project with some collaborators of mine
spread hither and yon in fact I'll begin
by thanking them just so that I don't
forget at the end looking at the
particular construct in psychology the
construct of episodic memory the the
ability as it's roughly defined to
remember events from your past
experiences to remember past experiences
from your life and this has been an
interest of mine since I was an
undergraduate when I wrote my honors
thesis on Locke's theory of personal
identity which ties the identity of the
person over time very strongly to
continuity of consciousness and
connections between memorial connections
between one slice of a person and
another slice of a person that's not my
interest today I got into this topic in
part because I was interested in what
episodic memory is and what it does for
us as people all let's see more about
that in just a second but before I get
into the details of this I should just
begin by thanking the people who've been
working with me on this
donna kwan pictured up in the upper
left-hand corner here collected much of
the data that i'll be talking about
Sheena Rosenbaum is my collaborator and
her advisor stan klein at the university
of california santa barbara shared some
patient data with me farah nave argick
adam provided some details about some of
music's that I'll be talking about along
the way developmental and musics in
particular Chloe Steinem and Ben Graham
are undergraduates well we're
undergraduate students of mine at
Washington University in st. Louis
Chloe is now at UCSB and Dan is here in
the law school somewhere Len green and
Joel Meyerson are the people that I've
worked with on the decision-making ass
effect of this talk and really what I'm
interested in is a question that's been
with me since my earliest training in
philosophy which is what I think is the
most puzzling question that philosophers
really have to address at the moment
which is to relate the fact that we have
two very different ways of thinking
about human beings on the one hand we
think about one another as the kind of
things that have beliefs and draw
inferences and make decisions and can be
held responsible for their actions the
kinds of things that we talk about
paradigmatically is moral agents and
reasoner's and then on the other hand we
have a view of the human organism that
comes to us from the sciences Sciences
like cognitive science and neuroscience
we're really human beings properly
understood or a set of dissociable
capacities implemented in mechanisms
throughout the brain and the rest of the
body and it's very difficult to see
somebody at once as both the kind of
thing that counts as a reason or an
agent responsible for their actions and
to see them as their behavior is the
product of these sorts of machines and
this talk today is really about trying
to put those two perspectives together
and part of the way that I think that we
could move towards the synoptic
condition of these two views of the
human organism is to ask both a
conceptual question and an empirical
question when we say that we come at the
human organism from these two
perspectives on the one hand we we have
to ask the question what what must a
human being be able to do in order to
deserve this status of being an agent or
a reasoner or the kind of thing that
could be held responsible for its
actions what sorts of capacities must
they be able to perform must they be
able to construct counterfactuals for
example or orient themselves in time or
figure out the consequences of their
actions or attribute values to the
consequences of their actions these are
the kinds of things that we would
normally assess when we're deciding
whether somebody was responsible for
their criminal activity for example but
then there's also just an empirical
question can people with different kinds
of cognitive deficit
do those things and I think we have to
answer both of those questions if we
hope to form any sort of synoptic image
here and part of this will involve
bringing the empirical vocabulary to
bear on what's a philosophical
vocabulary and they were not made to
match one another particularly well the
kind of approach that I've taken to all
of this with my collaborators is what I
might call a moral neuropsychology in
these cases I take it to be something
like the study of how specific cognitive
deficits for example different forms of
amnesia alter one's status as an agent
it's common in articles about people
with episodic amnesia that they're
described in somewhat infantilized
terms but they're no longer responsible
for the decisions that they make when we
do experiments with them we don't ask
them we don't only ask them for their
consent that we do ask them for their
consent we also ask their parents to
consent on their behalf we don't think
of them as able to make those kind of
decisions if they're signing a contract
or entering into an agreement or getting
married as some of them in fact do we
wonder whether somebody who's got this
kind of cognitive deficit is the kind of
thing that can properly be said to have
what it takes to enter into those kinds
of agreements so when I talk about
people in the space of reasons though
that it's that broad panoply of things
that I'm thinking of but on the second
part BIA and thinking is the study of
how different cognitive capacities
enable human beings to deserve that
status now one famous philosopher who
played a big role in training me John
McDowell is famous in saying that these
two things have nothing to do with one
another there's one language that we've
got for describing people in our
everyday interactions with one another
there's another language that we use
when we investigate the brain or the
mind scientifically and those two
languages do not match up with one
another and should not be expected to
they were formed for two entirely
different sorts of purposes on the one
hand for regulating our social commerce
with one another and on the other hand
for doing an empirical investigation
into the underlying mechanisms McDowell
in is one bit of nodding in the
direction of neuroscience says well of
course the brain of an agent can't be a
Oh genius jelly it's got to have some
sort of structure to it I would say
that's exactly right and really that's
the only kind of premise that I need to
get into this argument we can look at
how the brain is not a homogeneous jelly
the parts that it might break into and
how they contribute to this sort of
status my method is going to be a simple
one it's the one that's the mainstay of
cognitive neuropsychology and it's a
method of dissociations and in this
method you find a person who has lost
the capacity to do one thing a while
maintaining the capacity to do some
other thing B and what you're licensed
to infer from such a patient is that you
don't need a for B a is unnecessary for
B and and you might also call this a
kind of causal independence if I learned
that you can lose your episodic memory
for example to find that in just a
second and maintain your semantic or
procedural learning that suggests that
episodic memory is causally independent
of these others at least to the extent
that you don't need to have episodic
memory in order to learn semantic facts
or to learn procedures I should be clear
when I talk about episodic memory though
that I'm not always entirely clear
whether I'm merely talking about a
behavioral capacity the kind of thing
that we display when we tell one another
stories about what happened to us in the
past the kinds of things that we display
when we answer questions cues to tell
you about our favorite birthday party or
something like that or looking inside to
a kind of cognitive capacity that we
idealized inside of ourselves a
dedicated mechanism of some sort that's
responsible just for that and for
nothing else I'll be moving back and
forth between these two but I think
everything that I want to say today
could be understood if we only think of
these as behavioral capacities in some
way one premise of what I'm doing is
that episodic memory can be selectively
damaged leading many aspects of our
mental lives intact and the form of
inference here is that episodic memory
isn't necessary for those other aspects
of our mental lives these things are
pretty shocking and I almost didn't
believe it until I met some people who
had these forms of amnesia you can have
somebody with very high thought who's
very high-functioning and able to have
an incredibly intelligent conversation
with you in the moment but they won't
remember that conversation
five minutes later if you distract them
with a cup of coffee now and when you
see that for the first time it's really
it's very shocking but it is possible to
preserve these other capacities while
losing episodic memory the one thing
that I'll say as a methodological rule
for myself is that I try to confine
myself to negative claims to the claims
about dissociations if an individual who
has episodic amnesia has lost their
episodic memory succeeds on a task then
we're within our rights to conclude that
having episodic memory is not required
for you to succeed on that task you've
demonstrated it but if the individual
with episodic amnesia fails on a task
then one cannot infer that episodic
memory is necessary for success on that
task because they might have damage to
other parts of the brain that we're not
aware of they might have other cognitive
deficits that we haven't picked up on
but the negatives it seemed to me
constrain the positives here and if
we're going to tell any meaningful story
about the role that episodic memory
plays in our lives as persons we have to
first rule out some plausible thoughts
that we might have from our full
conception of episodic memory to build a
more plausible story and why am i
interested in episodic memory in
particular I've already mentioned this
John Locke character who seemed to tie
quite a bit of our forensic notion of
the person to our ability to bind our
the moments of our lives together
through Memorial linkages but it's also
the case that if you read a bunch of
cognitive science you'll find that it's
often claimed that this is a uniquely
human capacity that the capacity to
reflect on our past experiences and
relive and as it were relived them is
something that isn't shared even by
chimpanzees or bonobos it's it's
although there are some claims that you
can find it in elephants or in different
forms of corvids there are also a large
number of scientists that claim that
it's never in fact been demonstrated in
non
in organisms and furthermore I think
there's just a folk plausibility to the
idea that episodic memory is something
that plays a role in our lives as people
when we're terrified about the
possibility that we might acquire
Alzheimer's disease into the future one
of the things that people often express
concern about is that they might forget
their lives and that having forgotten
their lives they've lost pretty much
everything that they have to lose we
also when we think about children it
seems that it you know this this
capacity for episodic memory it's often
claimed doesn't really fully become
present in young children until they're
the ages around three four or five years
old depending on different people's
estimates and and we often think that
children beneath that age are not really
to be punished with anger but rather
molded and various ways not held
responsible for the things that they do
but we find teachable moments instead
right but once they get this ability to
keep track of what they're doing and why
we start holding them responsible so I
think there's a kind of surface
plausibility to the thought that this
capacity to remember experiences from
our lives is really important to how we
think about people quite generally and I
also want to look at this today in
particular with respect to time and the
sense that that people with episodic
amnesia have about time the dominant
metaphor that cognitive psych
neuropsychologist used to describe
people with episodic memory is that
they're trapped they're trapped in a
permanent present an eternal now right
so here are just a representative quotes
Roberts in 2002 asked the question do
animals have a sense of time episodic
memory and an ability to cognitively
project activities into the future where
our animals permanently similar to Casey
Casey is one of the subjects that I'll
be talking about in just a second and a
children under the age of four notice
the infantilization Casey and children
under the age of four and rats could
animals be largely stuck in a permanent
present with little ability to remember
past episodes or plan activities for the
future della Barbra and the court last
year say however a me two years ago say
however a music patients not only do not
consciously remember
past but also they cannot imagine their
personal future and are severely
disoriented in their present world in
light of these observations amnesia from
hippocampal damage as well as
confabulation cannot be considered pure
episodic memory deficits but rather
pathological conditions affecting the
individuals entire subjective
temporality the very idea that you exist
in time endl Tobin when he introduced
the concept of episodic memory in 1983
on the first pair actually one of the
last pages of the book says we can if we
wish close our eyes and think about what
we did ten minutes ago or how we
celebrated our last birthday and we can
think about what we might be doing
tomorrow or next year this kind of sense
of time makes a huge difference to what
we are and how we live if we retained
our other mental capacities but lost the
awareness of time in which our lives are
played out we might still you'd be
uniquely different from all other
animals but we would no longer be human
as we understand it it's a very strong
claim about the role of episodic memory
in our lives as persons and
understanding time arguably is central
to many of our a general capacities if
you don't know that there's a future how
do you think about the future
consequences of your actions if you
can't remember what you've done in what
sense can you be punished justly for
that thing and of course this metaphor
gets repeated time and time again sue
korkin in her book we recently wrote a
book about the famous patient HM who
after by loud but by a bilateral
surgical removal of the hippocampus lost
the ability to lay down any new memories
the title of the book is permanent
present tense the movie memento is
edited in reverse order in order to give
us a sense of the temporal
disorientation that somebody with
episodic amnesia must experience in
their lives and many of you have
probably seen the footage that's
available on YouTube and elsewhere on
the Internet of Clive wearing one of the
most famous and music subjects who
begins each day by opening up his
journal and writing down it seems what's
the exact phrasing now I am fully awake
for the first time and then he scratches
it out and writes under it
now I am fully awake for the first time
scratches it out now I am fully awake
and these kinds of this kind of evidence
gives us the sense of somebody who
really is trapped in the present and in
some ways just stimulus bound the only
thing that they have to deal with is
what's in front of them and that kind of
truncated outlook on the world would
would would severely hamper somebody as
an agent all right
that's all just by way of introduction
to the topic that I'm going to get into
and my claim is really that people with
episodic amnesia are in no sense stuck
in time and that these claims have
merely grabbed hold of the minds of the
cognitive scientists and have have
become elaborated over time into a
fairly complicated story that in fact
has never been tested and I'll talk to
you about some evidence that we've done
to really suss out what's left of the
amnesic sense of time in Asia and and I
think what this really does for us is is
to help us to back away from our
ordinary conception of what memory is or
what episodic memory is and to start
thinking about it in much more specific
terms the terms of a much more mature
science about what's actually going on
in these people who have this thing that
we use the term episodic amnesia to
describe so I'll begin first just by
talking about one patient to one person
who will be the center of my discussion
his name is Kent Cochran he died last
year he has he had the most severe and
well-documented case of episodic memory
of anyone in the world now then I'm
gonna go through different ways of
thinking about time and how we might
assay the sense of time in a person of
this sort I'll talk about some knowledge
of what James McTaggart called the a
series and the B series I'll explain
those in just a second I'll talk about
Zimbardo's work on temporal perspectives
and attitudes about the past in the
future I'll talk about the impulsivity
and risk-taking behavior of people with
episodic amnesia I'll talk about the
extent to which they're able to
attribute value to future situations and
I'll talk about their capacity to
anticipate regret and the reason I'm
interested in all of those things is
because those are
that's those are the things that those
are the things that we take to be
relevant for whether somebody is in fact
a full-fledged agent whether it's proper
to speak of them in infantilized terms
whether it's proper to deny them the
right to give their own consent or to
enter into an engagement with another
human being my if there's a main thesis
here besides the individual points that
get made along the way it's that the
human sense of time like memory is
cognitively complex and and isn't a
unitary thing at all and much of it is
in fact preserved in people with
episodic amnesia individual individuals
with episodic amnesia I'm willing to say
with with complete certainty at this
point are not stuck in time are not
trapped in a permanent present this
isn't this is an illegitimate extension
of a metaphor that's gotten out of got
out of control the hippocampus and the M
tells MTL system is not as many people
say a time machine all right this is a
picture of Kent and his family Kent's on
the right
his mother is sitting down in the front
father behind brother who has just been
married and the other brother who
functioned as the best man in the
wedding if you show Casey this picture
Casey was in an automobile accident
30-some years ago with and had very
severe forms of brain damage which I'll
mention in just a second but if you show
him this picture he'll look at it and he
can name all of the people in the
picture and he can say that it was
probably a wedding probably his
brother's wedding but then he notices
himself and he he says but what what's
going on with my hair and it turns out
that the night before his brother's
wedding
Casey decided to give himself a
permanent and show up for the wedding
with this new do to share with his
entire family he has no memory of having
done this he has no memory of being
evacuated from his house when the train
wrecked in the backyard spilling toxic
chemicals
he doesn't remember being on the boat
when his brother fell off the side and
was killed he doesn't remember that is
even very salient events from his life
and and
and the harder you push on him the worse
he seems to get the way he's been
characterized in the literature is
having a complete anterograde and
retrograde episodic amnesia that is he
has no episodic memories from his entire
life and and never did until he died he
also has an anterior grade semantic
deficit meaning that he has extreme
difficulty acquiring new semantic
knowledge about the world and he has
extensive cortical atrophy which is why
we have to be very cautious about the
the inferences that we make here this is
a terrible case for localizing function
in the brain it's a terrible case for
drawing direct connections between brain
structures and cognitive functions
he has bilateral medial temporal lobe
volume loss with damage to the
hippocampus and the parahippocampal
cortex and much more besides some septal
damage and damage to thalamus on one
side and there's a complete description
of that machine of Rosenbaum's article
what she does characterizes a whole
battery of whole set of batteries of
different tests that have been done on
Casey over the years to characterize the
pattern of deficits and the pattern of
preserved performance and it's really
quite striking on all of them you see an
extreme deficit in memory related tasks
episodic memory related tasks and almost
no deficit in the other columns
this led consideration of this case is
what led endow Paulding to introduce the
concept of episodic memory or was one of
the things that really solidified it in
his mind which he defined in in many
different ways over time but roughly he
thinks of them as memories of past
experiences of personal events
accompanied by awareness of one's
previously having experienced that event
this he says his audit what he calls
Auto noetic consciousness awareness that
you previously experienced the event and
he also calls this a kind of mental time
travel the ability to imagine yourself
in different times and places so to take
yourself from the here and now and to
move yourself to some time in
passed and when he characterizes these
he describes them it's important for him
to distinguish episodic from semantic
memory so episodic memories tend to be
about a personal past I remember riding
this rollercoaster the voyage with my
daughter a few summers ago
it tends to be experiential I can still
conjure up the the anxiety that I felt
coming down in the first hill
it tends to be emotive coupled to
emotions
it tends to be temporally and spatially
organized so I remember coming over the
top and going over a series of bumps and
then banking to the right at 90 degrees
flying around a circle and I can put
that all together in a sequence from
beginning to end only about the I
remember flying that well I won't
philosophers they will distinguish a
particular way of expressing these
thoughts if I say like I remember riding
the roller coaster and indeed skate when
I say it in in this form the flying is
always something that happened in the
past
alright semantic memories in content and
contrast tend to be factual memories
they can be located in the past the
present or the future I can remember
that Columbus is in Ohio I can remember
that that yesterday was what day was
yesterday Tuesday I can remember that
usually I can remember that yesterday
was Tuesday and I can remember that
tomorrow I have an appointment to meet
with Bob and talk about neuro imaging
and and those can be in the past the
present or the future
they tend to be propositional in nature
not experiential and quality they tend
to be cold
Columbus's in Ohio I don't have to have
any feelings about that or thoughts
about it besides just Columbus is in
Ohio and they tend to be conceptually
organized as I'm as I'm bringing out and
we say I remember that sigh rather than
just I remember flying I remembered that
science is something that could be in
the past the present or the future this
is just a gist to get you thinking about
the right sort of cognitive construct
that I'm trying to get across to you but
the idea is that there's a sort of
reliving experience a mental
time travel to the past it's that
language of mental time travel that
really captures the imagination and and
allows us to transport this concept to
new places where it wasn't before I
think the other thing that allows us to
do that is the fact that these people
who have damage to systems that are
involved in episodic memory are not just
unable to remember things about the past
if you ask them to imagine vividly
what's going on in their personal
futures they're unable to do that as
well
Randy Buckner has at one point claimed
that this might just be a
perspective-taking system generally that
it might be involved in remembering the
picnic that you had or imagining the
future in which you're helping to put
away the dishes or taking the
perspective of the person who's
wondering why you're not helping to put
away the dishes or taking the
perspective of a different spatial
location and the suggestion was not just
that this was an episodic memory system
but now it was a general perspective
taking system that involved moving
imagining yourself in different times
and places quite generally or in other
people's minds that latter one turns out
to be false Shaina my collaborator
Shannon Rosenbaum has shown that people
with episodic amnesia understand sarcasm
they read facial expressions they can
understand stories and understand the
motivations of the actors in the stories
so the idea that somehow they're unable
to put themselves into the minds of
other people is turns out to be false
but these other three are live options
if you asked why it is that we came to
think that episodic amnesia was
associated with death its deficits and
future thought as well as thinking in
the past it really comes down to one
conversation that's reprinted in almost
every article that I read on this topic
it's between endl tall ding and Cayce
and alas let's try the question again
about the future what will you be doing
tomorrow there's a 15-second pause and
he says I don't know do you remember the
question about what I'll be doing
tomorrow yeah how would you describe
your state of mind when you try to think
about it
another five-second pause this is blank
I guess if you ask him again he'll say
it's it's like being asleep or it's a
big blankness sort of thing or it's like
being in a room and there's nothing
there and having a guy tell you to go
find a chair and there's enough
there or it's like swimming in the
middle of a lake and there's nothing
there to hold you up with these are the
kinds of things that that he says when
he's asked both to think about the
future and to think about the past
Oliver Sacks in his book the man who
mistook his wife for a hat describes the
Jimmy G the lost Mariner as adrift on a
sea of time in part because he doesn't
have the ability to imagine himself in
the past in the future said this
conversation led people to plus this
characterization of mental time travel
led people to assume that somebody who
had these kinds of deficits must really
be trapped in the here and now and not
have any sense of their own personal
future if that's true then their status
is moral agents their statuses persons
in the ordinary sense of the word that
the kind of thing that you would make
plans with or rely upon goes out the
window
but is it true well the first thing that
we wanted to ask was just whether they
had an understanding of the semantics of
time and to do this we made use and and
there's a philosopher Christopher Lille
in 1998 wrote an article in which he
claimed that if you didn't have episodic
memory you wouldn't have any sense of
the difference between past present or
future because you wouldn't have any
experience to draw on in making that
sort of judgment to get at this question
we used an old philosopher McTaggart who
draws a distinction between two ways of
conceptualizing time on the one hand we
conceptualize time as being divided into
basically three three compartments one
in the future one in the present and one
in the past and we might in fact see the
present is a sliding window that reveals
more and more of the future and leaves
more and more in the past on the other
hand we might think of time more as in
the way that a physicist might the time
is just a sequence of events that are
arranged as earlier or later than one
another and this idea that there's a now
moving through it all is merely a
psychological construct or at least
that's that's how many people have
argued but we wanted to know whether it
would be possible for them to have
semantic knowledge of what the past
present and future are the idea that
there's a direction
to time that there's a causal asymmetry
of the past in the future so that the
past can cause the future in the future
can't cause the past and we also just
wanted to know whether they could take a
bunch of events and order them in time
sequentially so the first test was
really about the B series this is just a
series of events ordered as earlier or
later like a timeline that you would
find in a history book so we took a
bunch of events from Casey's life none
of which he remembers in any episodic
detail whatsoever but we put them all on
a on a sheet in front of him and then
asked him to arrange them on a timeline
it turns out that he gets the bulk of
the 20 items exactly right
he gets six of them wrong one that he
gets wrong he wasn't involved in it was
the Toronto Expo in 1967 three of the
ones that he gets wrong are accidents in
which he lost consciousness so here is
his motorcycle accidents in which he
suffered a concussion and lost
consciousness here is where he wrecks
his VW Bug and this is when he was hit
on the head with a bale of hay he
doesn't get those right but all of these
other events are in fact put in the
proper order relative to the current
current time but that doesn't tell us of
course whether he has any concept of
times changing it just means that he can
order these events in his life so we
decided to just ask him I said what's
the future and he says oh they're events
that haven't happened yet reasonably
enough what's the past their events that
have already happened can you change the
past now trying to get at causation no
can you change the future yeah how by
doing different things does what
happened in the past influence what
happens in the future yes he doesn't
he's not a very loquacious guy Casey's
pretty pretty quiet and you'll see that
some of the other people that we'll
interview later go on at great length
and a rather delighted and answering
these questions and thinking about them
there's what you do now influence what
happens in the future I guess so does
what you do now change what has happened
in the past no can something that
happens in the future change would
happen in the past
No if an event is in the future will it
always be in the future he says know why
because time moves on once an event is
in the past will it always be in the
past he says yes we asked him if he
could go back and undo a murder that
he's done he says that you could not we
asked him if he's ever read about time
travel and if you can say what it is he
says well it's to take a body and move
it to a previous era this finding has
now been replicated in actually it's
it's now six other cases of people with
extreme episodic amnesia and they're all
able to answer these semantic questions
I don't think this is a big deal it's
just it shows that either a episodic
memory is unnecessary for one to have
knowledge of the a series or that these
people that I've been looking at like
Casey da and DB acquired semantic
knowledge of the a series before their
brain damaged that's all we can really
conclude in these cases but then we can
look at people who've had developmental
forms of episodic amnesia so they've
never really formed an episodic memory
in their life they had some anoxic event
at childbirth that did damage to the
hippocampus and so so they've had at
least extremely truncated forms of
episodic memory their entire life here
I'm thinking about John who's in London
and HC who's in Toronto I won't read all
of these answers to you but just to give
you a sense of how they go first there
are a bunch of questions about just the
semantics of these things and whether
they can remember stuff we asked could
you give an example of something that
happened in the past and HC says well in
general man walked on the moon and
personally she says I went snorkeling
with my sister and my mom asking John
about it he notes that the Queen's
Jubilee is something that happened in
the past and asked if he attended it he
said yes but then asked where he was
standing when he watched the flotilla go
by he was unable to locate himself along
the Thames anywhere and I have it on
thority from people who live in London
that if you live in London you know
where you were on the Thames and which
bridge you were standing by thinking
about the direction of time things get
maybe a little bit more interesting we
asked if an event is in the future will
it always be in the future and why and
John says well no because it's got a
date to happen and eventually that time
will come and it will be in the present
and then in
in the past hc' says when asked once an
event is in the past would always stay
in the past she says yes it's already
happened
it can only happen once and if it
happens more than once it's a different
event not a bad thought even you know I
would expect that's about what I would
expect from an advanced undergraduate in
a philosophy course on time I think when
we ask about the causal order of things
can you change the past here John gets
really quite animated can you change the
past way says well it is possible it is
possible to change the past now how will
by going back in time but only if you
can travel fast enough and at the moment
we can't so the answer is no we can't
change the past but yes there's some
confusion here but clearly he's bringing
some elementary thoughts about physics
into the picture then we ask him can you
change the future and if so how and this
sends him into quite a quite a spin he
says we'll change the future only if
only if you think only if you think
certain things are going to happen in
your life and they don't just because
different events happen that's kind of
changing the future but it's not so the
answer is still no like you can't change
the past because although you can try to
change the future like you see in films
and things people try and change the
future per se but by their very by their
very by their very actions they do do
they do something different they change
the future anyway so yes you can change
the future but in a way the answer is
still no and it goes on and on and on
and on he's having a Star Trek moment
where he's thinking through various
thought experiments about changing the
future and it's not a perplexity about
the nature of time but rather it's a
it's a deep perplexity about the nature
of time not a surface perplexity about
the nature of time he gets what we're
asking him and he tries to answer that
question and he tries to do it in a
fairly sophisticated way these are those
people who have never had an art well
have had an episodic memory deficit from
from the time that they were born so I
think all we can conclude on the basis
of this is that either episodic memory
is unnecessary to acquire conceptual
knowledge of the a series which is
plausible enough or individuals would
develop
Amnesia's build conceptual knowledge of
the a-series from what few episodic
memories they managed to retain one
thing to think here is that knowledge of
the a series is semantic knowledge and
people with developmental amnesia are
capable of acquiring semantic knowledge
of different sorts some of them are
graduating from high school and one of
them is HD is about to become a
professional cook and if you think
there's an experiential component it's
not exactly clear why working memory
wouldn't suffice rather than episodic
memory all right
that's that's in a way the low-hanging
fruit and the easy stuff to test suppose
you think about temporal attitudes you
might know that there's a past a
presence in a future and know why
they're distinct from one another but
not care that it doesn't matter to you
whether something occurs in the past or
in the future if you ask somebody would
you accept you know if you were going to
get a painful experience would you
rather be in your past during your
future you might expect them to be 50/50
on that actually we should do that we'd
never ask them that one but the
prediction might be that episodic and
musics will exhibit a myopic focus on
the present with little concern for
their past in their future if they're
trapped in the present and if that
metaphor is accurate that might be what
you expect might expect them to be one
Zimbardo cause present present evenness
these are people who are these are Yale
undergraduates I think these are people
oriented towards the hedonistic
president presents self-indulgent
pleasure seekers that shirk all exacting
work
Zimbardo 2003 or alternatively they
might be fatalistic that is if they
can't imagine a future and remember
they've been living with the Cayce he
lived with his parents for the last
thirty years of his life and you might
think that if you have that if you have
episodic amnesia and you can't imagine a
future and remember anything that you've
done you might start thinking that
nothing that you do really matters all
that much so I'm not crazy about this
test honestly but it does correlate
reasonably well with certain measures
like divorce rates and graduation rates
and and drug abuse and these sorts of
things they're all questions that are
designed to just tap whether somebody is
somebody who lives for tomorrow or
spends a lot of time ruminating about
the past
if they do spend a lot of time
ruminating about the past do they think
positively about that pastor negatively
about that past or are they the kind of
people who just think only now matters
or nothing matters and and those are the
dimensions these questions different
questions get out different attitudes
and then you can graph them roughly like
this
here's being negative about the past
here's being positive about the past
here's being fatalistic about the past
hedonistic about the path of the present
and future oriented in some ways in the
middle here is the fiftieth percentile
on all of these the blue line here is
Kaycee and what I want to point out
let's the HC is the Green Line she's
she's here and what I really want to
point out about KC is that on measures
of present hedonism he's in the first
percentile not not even anywhere towards
the mean and when it comes to fatalism
he's down here in the second percentile
these are his lowest scores and in fact
it's also the case for this is da-da
comes in very low and nobody is above
the mean on this on this particular
score by the way these red dots are
Zimbardo's idea of the good life not
much past negativity lots of positivity
about the past fatalistic present
present hedonism reasonably high future
orientation reasonably high but that
doesn't mean anything
that's just in Bardot's idea of what
would be healthy and happy and good but
it's not there's no evidence backing any
of that out what really matters is the
50th percentile in the fact that there
you know Casey is at floor on these
measures in fact across all of these
people including developmental and
musics the dominant temporal perspective
tends to be either positivity about
their past or passe or future
orientation
none of them score highest in hedonism
or present fatalism so they're add not
only do they know that there's a past
present and future but they're at they
have attitudes about it and the
attitudes tend to be relatively positive
towards the future so what I want to say
about that is that episodic amnesiacs
don't avow a hedonist
temporal orientation and they're not
notably fatalistic either but again your
you might point out that there this is
just what they say what do they actually
do in these cases so here I wanted to
look at impulsivity and risk-taking so
you might think that if you're trapped
in the permanent present and stimulus
bound only in the here and now that you
would be very impulsive because the
future consequences of eating that
cupcake are nothing to you you can't
imagine those future consequences and
you might not you might not so much care
about them now is all you've got on the
other hand you might think of them as
risk-taking people the people who don't
care much about the risk that they're
undertaking in in their day to day
activities sued and orphaned corvallis
for example in 2007 claimed that this
mental time travel capacity gives us
knowledge of our own mortality so if you
lost that well holy cow there's no
reason not to do this
so this Casey impulsive or risk prone is
a nice task that's developed for patient
populations that dissociates these two
phenomenon so impulsivity is is
operationalized here is the desire to
act on the first possible moment for
acting and risk-taking is the design is
defined as going for improbable outcomes
that have high payoffs in the way that
this tests work is there's a computer
screen and it can either begin with five
cards on the screen or no cards on the
screen in the add condition it begins
with no cards on the screen and then
goes one two three four five cards at
any point they can tap the screen turn
over the cards and if the winning card
which will always be under one of these
cards but the winning card is present
when they turn it over they get a reward
and the reward is inversely proportional
to the number of cards that are present
on the screen so you get big payoffs if
you turn this one over and that's the
winner and you get very low payouts if
you tap the screen here and you turn
and there's a winner all right so if
you're impulsive and in the subtract
condition you start with five cards and
then go for three to one so the thought
is that if you're impulsive acting at
the first opportunity for acting then in
the subtract condition you should choose
in with five or four cards present and
in the add condition you should choose
with one or two cards present but if
you're a risk-taker the kind of person
who just likes gambling on low
probability but high payout situations
then you would expect that in either
situation you would be choosing with
very few cards present and that's
represented on this graph here's what a
impulsivity would look like in the
impulsivity would look in the subtract
condition you would choose with many
cards in the add condition with very few
cards neither would be no difference
between the two risk-taking choosing
with only very few cards and Casey
doesn't really fit any of those profiles
in fact if anything you see a kind of
conservative response bias something in
the direction of neither and in fact
when you test his probabilistic
discounting behavior that is you ask him
to trade you ten dollars for ninety
percent chance of fifteen dollars ten
dollars for an 80% chance of sixteen
dollars and you do this with Casey HZ +
BG there's also da over here compared to
controls you see no difference in the
extent to which they discount the value
of rewards with the probability of
receiving none that reward so if they're
trapped in the present they're trapped
in the president with knowledge that
there's a future and a past and a
present and they're trapped there with
attitudes about the past and the future
and the present and they don't seem to
behave impulsively and they don't seem
to be fatalistic and they don't seem to
be hedonistic and they don't seem to be
especially risk-taking individuals so
whatever they've lost by having lost
their episodic memory it doesn't seem to
be harming them
domains on these kinds of tasks but we
wanted to look at their intertemporal
choice so suppose that I gave them an
opportunity to trade $10 now for $15
next week or $20 a month from now or $30
a year from now we all have a natural
tendency we're all different in this
respect and probably are different from
one time to the next in some cases but
we all have a tendency to discount the
value of a dollar systematically with
times do one of the most well studied
behavioral economic paradigms that there
is now suppose that you didn't know that
there was a future or you didn't care
about the future or you were trapped in
a permanent presence
what would your discounting curve look
like well one prediction is that they
would just discount as steeply as they
possibly could that is the value of the
dollar tomorrow is nothing to me value
of the dollar today is everything and
that their curve would just go straight
into the ground a second possibility
this requires some setup there's one
hypothesis about why we discount the
future which is that we are counting the
value of the reward against the pain of
waiting for it so if we anticipate we if
we think forward in time and we
anticipate you know I could have that
cake tomorrow I could have more cake
tomorrow than I'm getting now but then
I'll have to wait for the cake and
waiting for the cake is so unpleasant
that that it reduces the value of the
cake in the future because it have to
subtract the unpleasantness of waiting
for it um these are going to be hard to
see from the distance but again we've
got da and KC relative to controls HC
relative to controls and DG relative to
controls and you can probably see it
clearest here here here here and over
here that that there's no significant
difference between any of these people
and controls on their discounting of
future rewards that is they discount
them at exactly the same rate by the way
the way that we characterized this is we
do an area under the curve analysis and
then compare the areas under the curve
and and
no significant and and that the reason
that's important is that it's
independent of any particular shape we
don't have to decide whether it's
hyperbolic or not we can just calculate
the area and deal with it that way if
you ask can see how he's solving these
puzzles he's not very helpful can you
say how you thought about these
decisions he says I don't know gut
reaction yeah what made you decide to
take that amount we asked him at one
point no reason what would you use it
for no idea how would you decide which
amount to take well I think of what
sounds like a better deal are you
thinking about what you would spend it
on no is there anything you would spend
it on no if you had the guest what would
you do with it I'd put it in the bank
that's like the classic semantic answer
I would put it in the bank if we push
him really hard he says he'll spend it
on beer that's his favorite answer if we
if we really keep pushing him on this
but he's not forming any idea of what
he's going to do with this money but
nonetheless he's exhibiting a kind of
discount of the future da who was an it
was an accountant said that he made
strictly economic decisions accounting
for interest rates and inflation that's
how he did the calculations
hc' said she tried to estimate how long
she'd be able to hold out
she's a very bubbly person DG said he
just did it on gut feeling but whatever
the whatever they're reporting about
their internal states their behavior
seems indistinguishable from people who
have fully intact episodic memory so
what I want to say about this at least
with respect to the first prediction is
that episodic and musics don't always
choose the immediate reward they don't
discount more steeply than other people
so it would appear that episodic
projection into the future wouldn't be
required for one to value future rewards
that's kind of important actually in the
debates about abortion in philosophy for
example it's often said that one of the
things that justifies abortion is the
fact that that the the fetus is not in a
position to imagine a future in which it
receives goods and that that makes it
not as not as special as something that
does have that
imaginative capacity about its future it
doesn't have a future of its own as the
is the claim if HC and kc can't imagine
the future that has devastating
consequences according to that sort of
argument this seems to suggest that now
they do have a future they think of
themselves as having a future and they
invested with its value that they don't
think that the future is value less
discounting conclusion number two this
prediction that they would just flatline
and be in the same all the way across
episodic a music's discount the future
despite their inability to imagine the
pain of waiting so it doesn't look like
the pain of waiting is responsible for
for their decision-making I don't know
I'm getting close to the end of time is
that is that right and I want to leave
some time for question and answers let
me just very quick this is a complicated
experiment this is it concerns the alais
paradox the alais paradox is a kind of
decision-making anomaly that we all
exhibit a kind of incoherence in our
rational decision-making here's how the
story goes if I offer you a choice
between a million dollars for sure or a
an eighty nine percent chance of a
million dollars
a 10 percent chance of five million
dollars and one percent chance of zero
most people in this situation I won't
take a poll but most people in this
situation will go for option egg give me
the sure million dollars and they will
do that even though the expected utility
of the second choice is greater than the
expected utility of the first and asked
why many people will say well I just I
imagine with my luck I end up over here
in the in the 1% that that where it
didn't work out in my favor if I offer
you instead a choice of an 11 percent
chance of a million dollars versus a 10
percent chance of five million dollars
most people will take the 10% chance of
5 million dollars
what's interesting about this however is
that if we block out that third
column over here these decisions are
identical the only thing that we've done
in that last column is add an equal
amount to either side of the decision
and it's a fundamental axiom of
decision-making decision theory that
your preferences shouldn't shift if you
add equal amounts to both sides of the
choice but we all do this a common
thought about why we do this is that we
anticipate regretting being in the 1%
situation and so people have developed a
theory called anticipated regret theory
in which they claim to factor in regrets
the possible future states and if you
factor in those regrets then you can
make it so that this ends up being a
rational decision on the part of people
who of all of us who make those kinds of
choices if that's your hypothesis then
people who lack episodic future thought
who can't imagine themselves in that 1%
situation who are trapped in a permanent
present wouldn't shouldn't be able to
anticipate that hot future regretting
situation and so they shouldn't make a
lazy in choices in fact Loomis and
Sugden who invented the anticipated
regret hypothesis make exactly this
prediction they say that some
individuals may experience no regret or
rejoicing at all in these special cases
of our theory we would predict that the
individuals behavior would conform to
all the conventional axioms of expected
utility theory so we put them in a
situation where they have to choose
between - high probability situations
and low probability situations between
two options really just setting up the
choice of the the elation choice
situation for them I don't know if I
should walk through all of this or not
but basically in a high probability in
what we should somebody who's in the
lazy insolation choices of this sort
should prefer risky investments more in
the low probability cases so here they
should go for the risk in the
sorts of cases the low probability ones
than in the high probability ones they
should always take the the top left
there and if we're looking instead at
losses instead of gains then you should
expect the reverse result and what we
found in fact is that KC in the case of
gains prefers the risky choices in the
low probability cases to the high
probability cases and among losses that
he prefers the risky choices in the high
probability cases rather than the low
probability cases in other words he's a
lazy and just like the rest of us so
either we're Araiza lazy n' for reasons
that have nothing to do with anticipated
regret prospect theory offers some
thoughts about that or there are non
episodic means of anticipating regret
like semantic anticipation or some
automatic projection system but the
point that I want to make through all of
this is that these metaphors that are
coming out of cognitive science that
people with episodic amnesia are trapped
in a in a permanent present are
powerfully seductive metaphors they're
extremely devastating in their
consequences for the people who have
these kinds of of impairments to say
that somebody has no concept of the
future or is trapped in a permanent
present to a stimulus bound is about as
devastating a thing as you could say
about somebody from an a general
perspective but here's what I think
we've shown if they're trapped in the
here and now in a permanent present as
sue korkin says they're trapped there
with knowledge of the past the present
in the future they're trapped there with
preferences concerning the past the
presence in the future they're trapped
there without being impulsive or prone
to risk-taking behaviors as a result of
all of this they're trapped there with
the ability to assign value to future
events and to make choices that respect
the value of future events and they're
trapped there apparently with an ability
to expect their own regret at making bad
decisions so it seems that episodic
future thought isn't required or the
ability to perform well on episodic
memory tasks does not entail that you're
somehow unable to conceptualize where
you are in time or or have a world
that's bigger than an instantaneous
present what's happened I think in this
situation is that the language of the
the psychological vocabulary of
cognitive science has gotten a grip on
us we start describing these people as
lacking mental time travel we describe
them that way in part because it's a
sexy way of describing people of this
sort it gets attention when you talk
about them as having mental time travel
difficulties but that metaphor gets a
hold of us and now we start running with
it we say oh they're trapped in a
permanent presence but we never even
think to ask whether that that extension
of the metaphor into these new areas
requires more evidence what more
evidence did we need then that initial
discussion with Endel tall thing after
all but it turns out that when you go
and ask the questions episodic memory
ends up being more puzzling in some ways
it's not a mental time travel device
whatever whatever it is and I haven't
even taken a stance on on what episodic
memory is but it's not a mental time
travel device and it's not the sole
source of our own subjective awareness
of temporality and it's certainly not
the keystone of our a gential capacities
because many of those are intact in the
absence of episode the ability to
perform well in episodic memory tasks so
the take-home lesson here for me is that
the ordinary concept of remembrance is
not the scientific concept of episodic
memory our ordinary understanding of the
relationship between episodic memory and
other capacities doesn't apply to the
scientific sense in many cases our
intuitive thought that episodic that our
memories of the past must be somehow
related to our sense of our own
temporality is is an intuition not not a
deliverance of fact individuals with
episodic memory deficits retain much of
their sense of time now I don't want to
overstate this people with these sorts
of Amnesia's are severely disabled and
have the extreme difficulty caring for
themselves it's not surprising the case
he had to live with his parents for the
last 30 years and I wouldn't want to
downplay the significance of these of
these deficits but I but I do think it's
really important when we're dealing with
people with cognitive and
it's that we not treat them with the
one-size-fits-all incompetence category
but rather we ask the question given
this particular sort of deficit what are
the consequences of that for their
ability to live a full-fledged human
life and that we that we fully explore
those possibilities before we foreclose
them with our metaphors there's a lot
that we could do going forward that's
that's really the end of the talk that I
wanted to give today but let me just
want to say one last thing if this is it
all interesting to you and you care
about this kind of stuff and you care
about people with memory deficits Ben
Graham the student that I was mentioning
to you earlier who's now at Yale Law
School and I found this old video of a
patient who as a result of carbon
monoxide poisoning was claimed to not be
able to hold anything in consciousness
for longer than one second and we found
a film of this patient that's about an
hour long involving an interview with
Gustav stiring who's depicted here in
the back and he explores many of these
questions about what could be left in
the life of a person who was no longer
able to store anything in even
short-term memory stores and so far as
we can tell it's about the most extreme
form of a working memory deficit that
we've ever seen characterized so if
you're interested in these kind of
phenomena you might check out this
article in cortex this article is called
remembering mr. B and there's a link to
the film there and it will totally be
worth the hour of your time that you
spend watching it I guarantee it alright
that's the end thanks
I'm actually a little bit puzzled that
in this whole field the episodic memory
consequences are actually conceptualized
in such a temporal way when already the
definition points to an important
emotional difference right it is about
you know the sort of the hot and the
cold of the semantic and episodic and it
seemed a lot of the examples that you
give about impulsivity seems to be more
a lack of actually caring about
memorable emotional future events you
know thrill-seeking you know impulsivity
and so on you you're not making taking a
risk just to make a risk but because you
get a train'll in russia and then
remember it as something positive you
can tell other people about right i mean
that seems to be a dimension that is
much more salient to the question rather
than this question of temporality itself
the only reason that i'm focus you might
want to stay by there cuz i'm gonna ask
you to clarify the question there's
there's there's no doubt that there's an
emotive component to what's going to
what's going on here the the way that
episodic memory was the reason that that
i'm discussing it in these terms is just
that the literature itself discusses it
in in terms of time and so i'm just
taking their version of the hypothesis
and running with it now why is it that
they've focused on that rather than the
hot and emotional side they have also
focused on the hot and emotional side
but but as far as I can tell that that
elaboration of the story in endl
Holdings hands in 1983 was one piece of
like 20 different things that he would
list is important about episodic memory
more important were things like the
spatial and temporal organization of
events the hot component
I think was you know in part brought in
to explain the apparent importance of
this phenomenon to us but so but I'm not
sure I'm addressing your question yet I
sent something more in it it seemed to
me it's it's more about what role
emotions and anticipated emotions and
remembered emotions play in regulating
behavior to rather than questions of
orientation in space and time right so
all the examples that are not following
the predictions are actually ones that
can be easily understood at least
intuitively for a person like myself as
having to do with how they relate to
emotional what don't remember emotional
reaction I'm not that's the part that
I'm confused there because they don't
see how the emotional story would
explain the fact that they're identical
to us on all of these measures it came
up in the context of impulsivity right
yeah if I'm not thinking about negative
consequences of you know eating cupcakes
all the time right but of course I'm not
eating cupcakes because it's just good
in because it makes me feel good right
it's a sugar rush and and whatever
always with real seeking it is something
that has to do with my my emotional
future but if that doesn't work you know
if that doesn't in some way it doesn't
work you know then impulsivity is not
that it's not a predicted property of
this kind of patience said in that case
the the story would say that the
emotional reaction was what these sorts
of studies which show is that those
emotional reactions are not required
that that they hot emotional reality
whether we're taking it is about time or
about that it seems that we would still
be making the same pretty maybe not on
impulsivity but unanticipated regret
certainly what we're getting out of them
is yeah said suppose that you take away
the the hotness of the future thought
then then what you would expect is that
they would they would collapse into a
utility oh sorry they would they would
collapse into a straight utility theory
sort of response but that's not what
they do
maybe my question was just an emotional
response to what you said for thanks for
great Carl so I wondered how much you
might think of the results you have is
challenging the idea that episodic
memory is a natural kind rather than
thinking of it as challenging the
association of episodic memory with
temporary experience in other ways yeah
that's that's a great question
that one I get so the the I have I have
grave doubts about episodic memory as a
natural kind and the more that I work
with this there's a kind of cognitive
neuropsychology is a very strange
discipline in many respects and one one
aspect of the strangeness is that if you
ask me you know what is Broca's aphasia
like one reasonable answer is Josef
bogan once said is is it's what Broca's
aphasics do what severe entities
aphasics loads what Verna Keys aphasics
do what is episodic memory it's what
Casey can't do and a lot of the evidence
that we have for the dissociation and
the distinction between these is from
these patients we're helping ourselves
to the assumption that in fact would
they've damaged something rather precise
and that it's knocked one thing out and
left everything else intact but it might
be that what we're dealing with is
really something that's quite Messier my
inclination on all of this has been to
get much more fundamental I mean it's
clear that what I'm doing is pushing
away from the temporal way of thinking
about episodic memory and not thinking
of it as some sort of device that
mentally transports us here and there to
the extent that I want to give it a
mentalistic discreet
and even take any sort of positive steps
on this one one unifying hypothesis
here's a better way to say it one
unifying hypothesis that comes out of
contemporary cognitive science is that
we have an event cognition system of
some sort and what that system does is
it generates details and binds them
together into either actual remembered
events or possible events going forward
and my colleague at Washington
University Jeff Sox is one of the the
pioneers in this sort of area and if you
come in if you come at the system from
that angle you say that the brain has to
parse events it's got a it's got a parse
what happens in the world and and it's
got to store those happenings and it's
got to anticipate future happenings of
that sort and if you think of this is
really sort of an event processor rather
than a time travel device then then
maybe what's lost in these patients is
not so much the ability to transport
themselves in time but rather the
ability to construct rich events of some
sort and and then the fact that it's in
the past and in the future is not so so
surprising you get that for free but but
but the fact that it's past or future is
not the the central feature of the
phenomenon so one very natural way to go
is to say like well maybe episodic
memory so construed is this forward and
backward mental time travel device isn't
the right way to think of it but rather
we should think of it as an event
construction system that's been damaged
that and and is that push it's there's
still a kind e a natural kind sort of
thing that I'm talking about there but
it's a very different natural kind than
the one that we started with at the
beginning yeah yeah
that's right and in fact David Rubin and
Sharda Ouma not out of Duke are just now
coming out with a paper in which they
claim that the core phenomenon here is a
sort of event memory and that whether
that comes with an experience of
reliving whether it's hot or cold
whether it's a whole other traumatic or
not bias towards negative or not there's
a core thing which is event can
something like event memory and then
these different ways of modifying it so
I think part of what we really what
we're trying to chip away at here is
just this one characterization of the
thing is essentially time involving and
to move it towards something else and
that something else might be something
of this sort Thank You Carl I would like
to wonder if you could reflect on the
maybe the the sociology of this how does
how does this happen in science that
perhaps a colorful or attractive
metaphor becomes incorporated and then
in you know because it was helpful at
one point or maybe dr. could straighten
themselves and then becomes part of how
people think of that area of science I'm
thinking of elsewhere my own discipline
the the The Selfish Gene you know which
as a cartoon that has incredible power
with all these same kind of consequent
problems to it starting with not
popularization though is it the fact
that everybody these cases are so
colorful and fantastic that people
outside psychology like them or does it
happen in regular science too good
that's that's that's a great question I
think it happens I think it can happen
anywhere and that you know when we start
labeling genes like you know an obesity
gene or that that's exactly the kind of
thing that will also grab our attention
and focus it in a particularly that it
will direct the way that we do research
on that gene to think of it as a gene
that's associated with autism or a gene
that's associated
obesity or something like that and that
and and I'm not gonna play amateur
sociologists and think about what you
know what are the mechanisms for meme
generation and what keeps them going
over long periods of time in this case I
think it is a sort of color from color
for colorful metaphor coupled with the
very seductive way that we think about
memory in our everyday lives we tend to
think of it as this kind of mentally
transporting experience people write
about it that way in literature and and
so I think that there's that it's partly
that we start with I think it's a
particular problem with the cognitive
sciences or sciences of the Hmong
psychology if we start with our folk
psychological categories the the
everyday language that we use to talk
about one another's thoughts and beliefs
and and the way that we move around in
the world that that has built into it a
whole host of assumptions about what
drives us to behave in the ways that we
do and the psychological vocabulary is
often often using exactly the same words
to describe different phenomena but but
the fact that we're using and part of
the way that we sell the project to the
public part of the way that we get
funding from the project part of the way
that we tell other people that it's an
interesting project is by associating it
with these folk psychological notions
but this Volk psychological notions come
with a bunch of laws about what memory
does for us and and those come along for
free into the scientific endeavor but I
don't think it's just I don't think it's
uniquely in the neurosciences I think
there are places like in in biology
elsewhere in biology where there's an
idea that takes hold and it and the
concept in a way the word my friend
Susan Fitzpatrick it calls it calls it
semantics creep that you've got some
some term and that suddenly the meaning
of that term starts broadening out and
encompassing more and more things over
time maybe autism you know I mentioned
autism already but there's there's a
phenomenon right autism one in 10,000
and
1880 diagnosis one in 88 today now
there's a term and that term is now
creepin out and being applied to more
and more things but we're not really
sure what's driving what what regiments
the application of that term so I don't
think it's just in these sciences I
think it's I think it happens in many
places but I think it's something that
we have to be yeah a good scientist
needs to very very much be aware of and
on guard against it's a very big subject
because it also involves the cognitive
psychology that told to living was
discovering or creating which neglects
not only this the taste of chocolate but
neglects the whole dynamics of human
emotion and which is not accounted for
in that field the great success of that
field is said as it is that it is
identified the parameters in this case
personal experience versus impersonal
experience which become which are
causative parameters so that the whole
subject that of that tooling has created
which is a very popular field should
sync with this with these experiment
with these criticisms but so it isn't
just the one particular thing it's that
it is a this is the present state of the
large section of psychology and
neuroscience and so it's not just any
particular aspect that is giving it
wings it is that the the whole the whole
set that whole system is polluted by
tool things discoveries that makes this
talk a much more significant talk and
you towed that a thread yeah yeah I
think that I think what I'm trying to
tag on here is something that could be
tugged on in many diff
areas of cognitive psychology and and I
think that you know there there is a
lesson about keeping ones hypotheses
relatively close to the data that one
has collected and keeping ones
constructs fairly well regimented in
terms of measures that we can assess
episodic memory is typically assessed in
us in a kind of autobiographical
interview where I give you cues
birthdays and then you tell me about a
birthday party or I say like you know
vacations and then you tell me about a
vacation that you took
that's one tool for getting at it there
are thirty other tools that one might
use to study something like this
phenomenon but regimented those and
telling when we're in fact getting at
the right capacities is I think a
crucial piece of doing cognitive science
well and I think it is something that's
often forgotten because we find a
favorite technique or a favorite way of
reproducing the phenomenon and we stick
with that so yeah I think there's I
think as you know I I think there are
broader problems than just the episodic
memory case my answer to Chris was much
more conservative in wanting to keep the
idea that there are cognitive capacities
and that they're worth trying to
decipher I could imagine a future
neuroscience where where that might no
longer be the reasonable way to to see
I was wondering if these these people
can be conditioned most memories are are
not there there are a lot of memories
that are subconscious that are repressed
they're displaced that might be stored
in different parts of the brain for
example so I was wondering if anybody
has done any sort of psychoanalytic kind
of studies on these people whether for
example if they've had a phobia in the
past does that phobia disappear is it
still there
can you condition them in the future to
create a phobia in them even without the
implicit memory yeah I don't think that
I would get the latter experiment by the
IRB board I have so on the on the first
question I think that the dominant
orientation of contemporary cognitive
psychology / neuro psychology is though
occasionally there's lip-service
to psychoanalysis considers itself
largely separate from from that that
tradition and so so to answer the
although I spend a lot of time reading
Freud and others psychoanalysts that
tradition for sociological reasons
doesn't tests who has not tested those
hypotheses now as for conditioning
conditioning has been tested not not I'm
not talking about repressed memories or
recovery from symptoms that result from
repressed memories but but if you just
want to know can they can they learn to
improve their tennis swing or can they
learn to be scared of a doctor with a
pin in their hands that keeps ticking
them
in the hand the clapper ed test is a is
a common test that's described with with
it's actually shown in this video that
somebody with with a very severe memory
deficit you want to see whether they can
still pick up start becoming hesitant to
shake the hand of a doctor who's hiding
a pin in it and Cayce passes this test
eventually stops shaking the doctor's
hand and when asked why he says because
sometimes doctors have pins in their
hands not not not because you just stuck
me but because sometimes doctors have
pins in their hands so there's a there's
a there's something getting in there
it's very semantic not episodic in
nature and and but but but conditioning
different forms of conditioning and
cueing are still totally operative in in
these guys now as for the psychoanalytic
questions I just think that does it not
does have not been been tested we have
been interested in in dreaming actually
and and whether you would get character
you know it's now thought that that
sleep is a period of profound memory
consolidation and and I would be very
interested to know about brain behavior
during sleep in somebody who is not
remembering anything and whether you
would still see the characteristic
changes that you see in people that are
thought to be associated with memory
consolidation I think that's the best I
can do on that one
you